باعتقادك العميد الياس ما اهم التحديات
التي تقف في وجه هذه الاهداف خاصه لدى
واشنطن ليس فقط فيما يجري في اليمن ولكن
بدائره اوسع عما يجري في سوريا وكذلك في
العراق
اولا الاهداف المقصوف اليوم اذا اخذنا خط
تقريبا من تعز وباتجاه الشمال هي تقريبا
على خط عمودي من الجنوب الى الشمال وكانها
منضم
مواقع عسكريه وسائل عسكريه
تستهدف البحر الاحمر من باب المندب وحتى
شمال
الحديده اليوم التحدي الاكبر هو ان تقف
هذه العمليات يعني اليوم لا يمكن للحوثيين
ان يتراجع عن هذا الامر ولا يمكن للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان يتم تحديها الى هذه
الدرجه وان تتراجع وهذه مشكله كبيره لانه
اليوم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بسبب
هذا الحجم الكبير يجب ان تحقق شيء ان تؤمن
بالحد الادنى الملاحه البحريه بسلام وتمام
كما يقال ولكن اليوم هذه العمليه والقصف
اثبتت عبر التاريخ انه القصف من الجو وحتى
من البوارج وحتى الكروز مسر
والتوهه لا تؤدي الى شيء معين دائما يقول
الخبراء انه لتامين فعلا بحر اليمن او
البحر الاحمر على الجبهه اليمنيه هناك سهل
تهامه سهل تهامه طوله تقريبا على الشاطئ
الايراني من باب المندب الى الحدود
السعوديه ما يقارب ال 420 م وهذا بعمق بين
30 وال50 مكم اذا اردت فعلا ان تحمي
الشواطئ او تحمي الساحل يجب ان يكون هناك
تواجد عسكري غربي او تواجد عسكري معين
ولكن هذا امر صعب جدا لانه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا تريد هذا الامر ولا
تريد التورد اثنين يعني تحدث حضره ال
الادمرال على موضوع الكول عبد القادر
موضوع كول موضوع مختلف تماما تماما في
الظروف الدوليه في الظروف الاقليميه وحتى
في ظروف اليمن وحتى في فتره صعود القاعده
وبعد تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه اليوم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مختلفه في وعي
مفهوم الامن
مفهوم الارهاب ومحاربه الارهاب اليوم
التحدي الاكبر كيف تقيس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نجاحها ان يتوقف الحوثي اليوم
الهدف هو خفض قدرات الحوثي عز
عزله
عن عزله عن ايران والتوصل الى مرحمه معين
اعطاه دور معين اساسي ولكن هذا الامر يجب
ان يرتبط
بال الاتفاق مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
عندما تم وقف اطلاق النار وهذا من ضمن
صفقه كبيره جدا وهذا امر بعيد حتى الان من
التحقق اليمن او الحوثيون مشكله كبيره
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا يمكن قياس
النصر عليها وكما قلت اليمن
هي حرب انبل لا يمكن ان تربح الحرب اتى
العثمانيون
اتى
اتى جمال عبد الناصر الرئيس الراحل جمال
عبد الناصر بالستينات هذا حتى الانجليز
حتى البرتغال هذه المنطقه صعبه جدا لا
يمكن ان تربح حرب فيها يجب التعامل بطريقه
مختلفه الحل بالسياسه وليس
بالحرب جزء مما ذكرته قبل قليل العميد
الياس انقله الى الكوماندر ليوبولد فيما
يتعلق ب
ما تريد واشنطن وكذلك لندن تحقيقه من خلال
هذه العمليات في اليمن قبل قليل عميد
الياس قال يكفي ان تطير مسيره واحده وتنفذ
عمليه في البحر الاحمر لتسقط كل هذا
المجهود الامريكي البريطاني في الماء ماذا
عن هذا
التحدي كوماندر
ليوبولد اعتقد لسوء الحظ هو محق عندما
ننظر الى الحقائق التي قد يكون هنالك
مسيره واحده وهي غير مكلفه نسبيا هي تعيق
الشحن البحري خ عبر البحر الاحمر وايضا
خلال مضيق باب المندب لدينا طريقه جديده
للحرب واعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
بالاضافه الى الكثير من الدول وعندما
نراقب الصراع وكيف تطور بين روسيا
واوكرانيا فان حرب المسيرات قد دخلت ادخلت
تغييرات جديده وما اعتقد ان مساله اسقاط
المسيرات ونحن نقوم بهذا بشكل فعال اعتقد
ان المسيرات
التي قد تكلف 4000 دولار التي تسقط بصاروخ
قد يكلف مليون دولار هذا امر
غير جيد لكن كما قلت يجب ان نجد طريقه
للضغط على ايران ونوقف تمويلهم للحوثيين
وبعد ذلك ايضا ايران تضغط على الحوثيين
مره اخرى للاعاقه الملاحه كما قلت هنالك
الكثير من الدول التي تاث ثرت مصر والدول
في المنطقه في الشرق الاوسط التي تحاول
شحن النفط عليها الان ان تنتظر عشره ايام
اضافيه لمرور هذه الشحنه في القرن
الافريقي بالتالي نعم هو سلاح صغير هذه
المسيرات لكنه يغير شكل ووجه الحرب لكن
علينا ان نتا قلم مع هذا التغير لكي نتغلب
عليه